[Music]
hey what's up everybody I can't really
hear myself now I can um happy Monday to
everybody having Monday night good
Monday what's up guys how are you it's
time for some NBA 2k that we can only
play once let me go game here yeah we
can only play once so prelude demo for
NBA 2k 18 is out we're going through I
guess our vitals we got to make our name
here I'm thinking we'd be first name
game last name spot oh my god that's
such a horrible name I love it alright
whatever I'm gonna have to live with
this one so alright save data carries
over right so I guess we should give it
a little explanation of what's going on
what everyone's seen right now so this
morning they announced the NBA 2k 18 pre
Luke demo where you get to play I guess
the first we don't know how long how
much time we have with their to find out
we're gonna find out ah I don't know
what's going oh yes favorite dubs gotta
be the doves New York Knicks outta here
you Knickerbocker you're so you're so
lucky that Phil Jackson's outta here old
character creator let's go the eyes look
pretty good I'm not gonna lie I'm gonna
turn down bust a little bit cuz it's a
little bit a little bit much things
gotta be back we gotta be back do that
again
so should we be creating a monster
should we create I think create a
monster let's deal monster Peter Brown
says what the hell's wrong with your
face
alright let's start let's start with
your something very generic this face
looks very normal so I'm just gonna go
with this face here Wow skull with get
that skull wit alright so CL wad wait
doing it I really didn't make much of a
difference did I think I think I'll fool
you guys go fool max go alright max go
with I want like a charlie villanueva
all right max art school fight he won't
I was gonna say get rid of the brows but
I guess you can the brow meter is
already at zero
we're gonna find all right so browse now
you're at the snow height so give him a
nice 5 head oh what'd I do
my bad scroll down wow there are a lot
of option like this all right Ringo max
are we just gonna max out everything one
guy said the other one looked like Mike
Bibby here we go max brows yeah all
right so that kind of just adjust yes
okay eyes think I'm real big these are
not these don't make much difference big
difference yeah all right skim some wild
eye color at least like orange no one
orange for games bike no one has lockers
oh it's amber sure so it's just light
brown rock green you guys look good no I
they look alive they look alive there's
very uncool here raising with the nose
here oh it's just shrinking oh yeah are
they just different variations they
don't go up in size right or is it going
up inside ah looks opposite so it's like
different types of noses yeah give them
the big one all right the big one oh
here's I think the closest ones are
those hey it's your player bro okay all
right big mouth okay big mouth little
pucker on right now keep going right I
want that real awkward one yep that one
oh God our chin sorry it's getting
smaller one oh yeah well what about that
really thin the real chiseled one all
right
I've everyone I'll give you one since
I've been calling with the other ones
this actually doesn't look that bad I
know we're trying to make a monster ooh
not a lot of hair options is this really
the only hair option all right okay that
looks like you rubbed some like mud on
your head okay that looks like hair that
you had the best hair
selected I think like out of all the
hairs that are available yeah trying to
make something weird so pick pick
something weird gonna go with weird yeah
here we go
that is we are on ps4 currently making a
making a new character let's keep going
all right hair color going
can we go with any wild colors no we
cannot this alright next I browse
alright here we go
alright no eyebrows very small eyebrows
can you go no I reg there's a there's a
top that's it already happy yes I
believe right okay complete okay so what
we got here we have begin my career 2k
you my player 2 K 18 info so I guess
we'll deal with do get like yeah my
career also disclaimer I'm a little
rusty that's all good haven't really
played since last year but select your
team I thought I already did this wait
we're the next oh thank god miss the
Golden State Warriors get out I will
never never best team in the league
alright sorry that I missed some of the
chat I just wanted to get through making
that character yes in case we want to
break that out for something like that
273 you like warlock that's it black
plant from South Carolina 287 Titan come
at me bro
NBA live 18 is the way to go says Thomas
Ashley that would be interesting if live
finally finds a way to kind of like at
least even things out I don't know this
game has always looked so good oh wait
yeah turning up the gameplay guys
he's wearing Jays man oh yes
[Music]
oh yes the backs of DJ yeah I don't know
starring GameSpot as DJ are you serious
that is so cheesy you would never make
that where are you in Brooklyn or is
this some like fake city docks the 2k
zone
[Music]
okay now we're talking I like I like
this
well streetball camp here and no one has
had their registration former ID our
registration form well how do you know
you're supposed to be playing
I got a confirmation email yeah it
should have been attached to that email
I think an even love interest already
during events are always crazy can I
fill it out no well someone else got to
you so might as well Wow oh we get to
control the iPad Oh were you gonna play
oh oh this is good alright okay I play a
little ball I'm not crazy good but you
know I I like to think of myself as a
shooting guard small forward I have to
say for you you're probably a book ya
know I'm probably point guard so what
what would you like to kind of know I
hate reality obviously sorry someone
else like a klay Thompson a 2-way star
no I would just go point on Russell
Westbrook one of a kind what kind of a
point guard do you think you would be do
you liking yourself more Kyrie Irving
Wow offensive gotta got up stud support
my new jersey brother who's now a Celtic
look at how small he gets from here to
the hair center two point guard what do
you expect I'm going point guard okay
alright alright
is this how you spend your points right
I believe so so passing ball handling
driving finishing oh wow want to be like
you want to be like hire you right
you want to go WOW shocked creating a
shock reading yes
that's Steph Curry all right whatever oh
yeah Kairi you you want to be a driving
oh you get secondary okay oh I get a
secondary yes all right all right then
I'll pick what do you want to be driving
drum machine is definitely Kairi right
Kay yes I think so with maybe like he
has a good jumper and a three-point
shooter yeah and then three-point
secondary okay I like that yeah okay
I mean hey we did pretty good he's
wearing the wrong jersey ginger hi how
tall is Kyrie I can look it up I think
this is his height I think that is high
Oh
so as you're going up guy to got a guy
he's like three six six three and a half
I think six three we go six three yes
six three god I wish I was six to be
sick Oh a little wingspan I think it's a
realistic one baby you don't want to be
the Greek freak no to the Greek beat oh
you see his hands I saw some hands on
Twitter this morning they're huge
they're the biggest hands that are seen
bigger than obj is their giant these
hands are not real life I don't think
you want to make your guy look too crazy
or maybe you do so what's max so if we
give him access everywhere that stud it
doesn't actually look that much like a
monster we'll go we'll go max Arriba
what does it look like heavyset oh well
you know what it's doing
oh there you go change the look all
right but it's that's doing though with
your weight is it's changing like your
abilities here on the side right yeah
obviously all right so you're a driver
right that's even dude but how much how
much is um how much LeBron way Kim
probably 225 even more 250 yeah it's I
thought all right 200 seems good I 200
seems safe
oh wait wasn't you all your other stuff
down though
I thought you go is even one night so
even there's 198 and do that then all
right you're good all-rounder boy always
wingspan I mean look at that
oh shoot so we don't want it this way
yeah cuz you want to be able to alright
so that's where we want him all right
we'll keep even keel there
this isn't effect anything just makes it
look buff right Oh God have some posture
damn alright right-handed yes what are
you left right maybe lefty righty ready
fine left just a reason right he is I
didn't feel like in sports everything
looks better left uh what number should
we be my favorite number is 11 alright
klay Thompson oh are you from what a
strange sorry
Oh from high school this is cool you see
that from high school I did how do you
go from how do we go from actual
destinations I know I can and like to
just huh well a lot of a lot of teams
will do that alright so you know where
I'm reelin they don't they don't stay
say where they're actually from a lot of
those kids will come right out of high
school where it is look at that North
Carolina A&T that's kind of cool
NC State alright so North Carolina's
Elon yes let's go you're sharp shooting
slasher alright I like this alright
let's do it
are you sure yes I am positive
thanks dude you're good yeah that's the
first game and just a little bit but in
the meantime okay thank you
you're so welcome atm
here comes ATM what's he is he gonna be
the rival no isn't that Ronnie 2k next
to Russ yo Ronnie to cave in the game
hey maybe I should introduce myself
yeah why is there cuz I'm gonna be on
the cover of 2k one day you better pump
your brakes
yo what up it you put my brace we only
gas up around here man and who are you
anyways I'm DJ you remember me first
name D last name J oh oh hey I know you
you the kid to quit ball for a couple
years to try to be the next funk Plex
right I mean what happened DJ ain't
payin out for you now what you need to
be doing is worrying about making it to
that showdown game at the end that's
where all the good players all the dudes
has been real about this life that's
what we gonna be uh I'm gonna push back
now I'll be for it now I'm gonna push
back a to you
I like that cuz you play like money
you're smart man but mama calls me Lou
okay well I'm gonna see you in the
showdown Lou money as me yeah maybe we
don't have access all the hairstyles hi
here we go
the dude Ronnie 2k is in the game there
he is
with Russell you see it who else is he
with I don't know who that third person
is we get at it I want see some ball
so I can't go over here oh can you turn
on subtitles
we had subtitles on it Wow I don't know
I will check later so what am I supposed
to hear we'll shoot around
[Applause]
we're gonna use that ball yeah I'm gonna
try maybe I go back and say hit the ball
wish I did oh here we go huh
did that triangle to choose your jump
shot
Oh perfect trophy you know I need to see
what says Harry Hart Sakaki yes all
right
that's all it was you don't want you I
don't think I could I try to you alright
let me try again use ball machine
alright price where she's jump shot
Kyrie oh there we go buckets
let's you know at least is pretty good
bring the ball requested ball right um
again Oh slightly earlier they would say
that was wet well from downtown
you don't got that range you don't got
the rain
oh man geez you're moving in - oh boy
alright if I go up here can i play I
don't know find out currently you guys
just so you know as a prelude devil you
can't get in there quite from the other
side so you guys can get this it's a
free I believe on PlayStation 4 and Xbox
one and also the cool thing is yeah we
did the cool thing is that you're safe
data will transfer over who wants to be
a actually yep so once you build your
under there's more obviously ankle break
ankle brace bracelet so what that says
yeah that's what I says oh he's got a
he's got Jordan eleven Conchords on man
they got the shoot like this gun ones a
lot of time on the shoes Oh hot sizzles
who we are what were ya know and one and
one mixtape are we supposed to be
watching this yes huh maybe we'll get
the call come in stop hand check in oh
oh
SWAT it Wow deep free because that name
DT Oh ankle bracelet again ankle
bracelets with the Jordan alone conquers
Oh broken with a lot Oh
alley oop somebody was asking if this is
on switch I think it's supposed to come
out on switch there right I will make
sure oh oh yeah yeah I think that guys
wearing 13 all white ones I'm nervous
how are you good
my warm-up shots went yeah I was acting
a little bit like airplanes all right
doing a little play-by-play all right
did your back go underneath in the jam
shoot it she did I guess I have to shoot
I mean hit me good Reeves
back out you Drina oh I don't think yeah
maybe I don't have the range for you
good rebound down you know all right go
for it oh stuff city I wonder if my
performance effects uh but what is it
draft stock in this situation er I don't
know at the proving grounds right now
maybe it's street cred double team are
you doubling double oh there you go who
touched it
reach-in foul on who me yeah and it says
your name you have one foul right now I
got a b-minus it's I gotta get some
points
[Applause]
oh go go go oh you should've Joe by him
oh my god what is uh what's layup in
this one I think you just gotta be
closer to the basket there like commit
to it as a full Drive and then hit
square as you're driving it oh you're
gonna way bad shot selection you got to
a c-plus oh I'm in trouble
my fizzle damn hot scissors carrying the
team it's crazy how much Jordan stuff
there is but I like it the Jordan logo
is in the actual demo logo too which is
funny
it says NBA 2k 18 free lewd with the
Jordan logo oh my god can you buy a
layup well it was a contestant you just
told me to be quiet
oh I like it try to get fight for
position this is to be underneath
three-second violations
how does that affect me I think you know
where you are in the key dude you're the
one in the key you're not defending your
dude oh geez
you're ice cold right now to see that
little emblem for being ice cold it's
gotta be like NBA Jam dude you gotta you
got to warm up go ahead cheat it oh my
god give me give me that Wow
good oh he's got dunk that he team
keep caring I need to get the XP if what
I said was wrong about layups you can
gonna tell me what the proper way is oh
no how did you guys not get that right
go to a see are we gonna get up to be
before this ends first 21 fight Wow
stick up stick them don't reach here
don't run
all right that moved you up to a c-plus
somehow he + Daniel guy standing a guy
you know this is League I'd be yelling
at you right now
oh here we go showoff
[Applause]
that's usually what happens like that
usually even in the NBA they're like
what do you mean three seconds like they
are so generous on three seconds in the
NBA cheese that puts a breakdown down
pochi don't reach got stay solid nothing
what I love the ball one
did it top of the key
yeah
good pass those good fats - cuz you got
three seconds you got three seconds
let's just switch the switch oh you're
gonna get body gear mismatch
[Applause]
don't worry cm be botched he's gonna
heat up right here [ __ ] it's holy [ __ ]
you won't try I can try
[ __ ] that
although fadeaway
screens will help your grade as well
thank you pour away in the Waller get
some pics first thing I see is that he's
pulled oh here you go
hi Cecil
[Applause]
she's gonna get involved he hasn't
played in like a year
give him a break everyone relax relax oh
I don't mind I would I would be giving
myself issues to shoot had done to K you
that makes sense actually it's quite
training try some training who is whoa
it's Nico says hey Nick Michael said
you're straight trash and stop dabbing
on him put your dabs are weak just so
you know yeah I know
tell him but we'll see we'll see
Michael's a little weak too so saved it
I don't know how he stayed in balance
she's
your shooter your shooter huh you're
taking some tough shots there you go
there you go that's good that's good oh
no everyone
oh you shot contested though yeah
Terrell Turner we're warming out we're
trying it out we're checking it out oh
here we go oh there it is oh my god it's
all good dude
alright we're giving it a the reigns
yeah if I knew what to do I only know
the shoot button too
[Applause]
it's slow I think if you hold the right
trigger its sprint alright there you go
good pass you're a b-minus now so we're
out ATM can make that right
oh wow the big man to bail out the bail
out the legitimate bail out right there
oh jeez
all right I got us Toby - with the
limited knowledge I knew cheese
[Applause]
I hope this at the end just pull me away
very impressive we lost them
oh yeah you killed it but what's the
next step you need to learn to eat what
you kill at some point right
and when you're ready for that you call
me you sir moves moves amazed hey man
don't forget my boy DJ you need a car
you got skills course you play hard you
get a car call me
don't lose that so see the agent guess
so players on the court
thanks gamer 32 Circle will get you some
screen got to work on our PG skills Oh
next game let's go you're playing with
another squad no it's not
no Oh cuz sorry I saw the number 11 I
thought that was your Jersey but you're
42
oh maybe it is oh here we go here we go
circle for screens the new team circles
circle for screens got 18 seconds here
Oh work it work them come on baby let's
wat that oh that guy looks like
[Applause]
what did I get negative for that yeah
thanks for the tips might have been
early on the there you go nice give us a
dime
Carlton McGriff to say I love the NBA 2k
18 Fraley but it was very short how
short was it was it indeed end up being
like a half an hour so that's a
breakdown I was on him hint
what does Mark Jackson say hands up no
he says hand down man down very well
mother close that man go get to the
basket there it is or not
Oh SWAT that
[Applause]
oh man I was 2k I would have gave you a
score break down there oh good pass a
terrible shot by that guy awful Oh
defensive breakdown good block
they'll pull up making it what archetype
we are with it driving and driving a
three-point at three point yeah driving
number one three-point on the two we got
to be more aggressive Wow
what was our center Newton Center was
sleeping only five games you only get
five games you need to K you that's
probably true oh I'll play the next game
if we get five games okay I need some 2k
you though
I need something I need some hot tips
guys give me your tips
boxing guys pretty helpful to ya you got
to always always put a hand on someone
don't let them get a easy easy oh that
was a great pick and roll excellent pick
and roll right there by the ai ai here
we go good pass Aspen pick
you can't force that you want God one
step forward three steps back
so you said right trigger was a turbo I
think so
or like kind of like those shaking bakes
or isn't it wasn't now in the direction
on the sorry on the left stick just like
[Music]
you can see being checked yeah all right
some to a woman
here's get a hand on them yeah right
trigger
drivel needs is left trigger so you
could do through the nose left finger oh
you just gonna shake oh I had a steel so
I can take a shot I like it
Oh transition three
[Applause]
also being told you get a good Smurfs
and just passing a lot get passed on you
gave us make the switch
yeah we got that right trigger oh this
guy's that's a tough shot kind of James
Harden it oh there it is
yes there we go that was a good Drive
right there this guy can't guard you all
day what's his name Prez so it says yeah
Prez Oh
[Applause]
Oh what are you doing that's a crazy
shot to take what she fell really no no
I mean that I may take it in balance
we're shooting for all why justice all
right here we go my trigger will give
you some intensity Oh Oh get that out of
here out loud offensive rebound I just
gone up with you on a tin box out I
guess jeez from downtown
I didn't even take a charge that's cool
I'll set it out there we go get back
this back in the shimmy she open in the
corner glad shoot it nope not a good
pass apparently eight seconds make a
decision
come on you got to tell them what to do
shoot her pass you're controlling him no
I'm not
are you sure yeah no I'm not because
from my perspective when I was playing
when I hold square they shot it they did
yeah did you try holding square there no
yeah well they pass back to you okay if
you tell them to do
there does nice
you didn't think that was a crazy shot
to take like that oh no man I'm talking
about the when the number-6 drove and
just try to force one up that's a little
mud there you go good pass
solid get it back put it back circle to
you there you go
skip pass yep all right here we go four
seconds
you gotta force it up or force a big man
to shoot it nope should he give it to
the other guy with so good ball movement
I guess cheese that guy doesn't miss
from three can't leave him alone
go
who has been also being told don't say
too close to while defending make sense
they got a quick first step they're
gonna take you nice
probably got j:2 going
[Applause]
I'm reading oh alright obviously it's an
option hi fizzles that goes great studly
get angry
we didn't we don't deserve to be early
that was I - nothing Romania I feel like
they picked that room by like three
[Music]
[Applause]
will something
Nowinski on switch says to smooth for
you got robbed out I doubted it man and
I'm playing your yeah
all right so this is the
so we still have another pre-games than
with this right
[Applause]
the proving ground
[Applause]
little dish that's what it was thank you
equip on twitch I can go back and look
at that for you but obviously we didn't
review the game we're just checking out
freely camera selection
[Applause]
no.5 oh you're on ATM oh my god okay I
was gonna say I feel like it's a
corrosive mismatch
[Applause]
like that down low for you
oh good ball movement - I guess so it
wasn't it didn't give us any points
though so it wasn't that good I'm just
gonna try to stick on my man
for those of you in the county played
both demos which ones you guys prefer oh
right back out to me all right whoa I
was open for three but he knew who to go
to that he was gonna get a rare shot I
guess
[Applause]
and help
a lot of people are talking about how a
lot of this game comes in two online
modes we don't know who I mean the game
well this game comes out next week
ish yes 19 so the 19 so it's pretty much
next week well stay on your man
[Applause]
nice
[Applause]
take it back we just okay okay
Iran they get
Oobi - so I've been passing that's about
it though you're an ATM boy oh he
crossed me up oh so a lot of people are
saying that the e a live demo was fun
but everyone seems to be having
preferences on YouTube and twitch at 4 2
K 18 2 K 18 I've always found has been
like character model wise has been
superior to live but I know live this
year has a story mode as well I think
it's called like the journey or
something like that if any one of the
chat knows got that rebound let's go
oops you and Twitter said take could be
grinding the destiny right now sometimes
even the greatest destiny players have
to step away from the game for a hot
second oh nice yeah nice sometimes with
the jumpers not falling you just got a
pass and hope you're a I teammates are
good
come on you atm ain't getting no money
here
switch
oh great theme oh oh a nice sit-down
nice rebound we see whiskeys skip castes
skip past rather but oh wow that's how
we do it
5:14 let's guy run that fast break get
that rebound run that fast break through
the pic bite through the pic whole tree
down nice
oh I'm so open oh ah thanks
Carlton would Griff on YouTube said it's
called NBA Live 18 the one so that's
their version of like a story mode here
sizzles hey what's up the red for
warming what's going on how are you
Oh buckets
[Applause]
I'm pretty good Nick you are path you
doing law passing a lot of passing try
to get like a couple points at least
okay all right fine if we can what was
that I know the foul they called I was
gonna say robot like three people he
gives me the ball to shoot it
don't forget the fast break if you guys
are on twitch hit the follow button if
you're on YouTube hit the subscribe
button so you're notified when we go
live we typically play games whatever's
hot every weekday around 11 a.m. Pacific
time so be sure to subscribe to let you
know what game we're playing when we go
live today tase taking a step back from
destiny what Oh
it's not gonna happen though she just
jacked up a shot yeah I don't know I was
jacking up a lot of shots and then were
falling oh no Thomas Ashley says that
MBA live 18 has wmba teams which is kind
of cool
but they've expanded their teams with
that I shot with the right stick - did
you really swear yeah you could do right
I forgot that you I did not want to eat
that
[Applause]
we should go back to passing good ball
movie now
oh no ATM just wouldn't yield it on the
win see on twitch says your opponents
are on a run catching up fortunately be
a playmaker alright there you go good
pass on a circle circle it's not I
thought it was earlier oh that's nice
that's nice offensive foul my guy
oh no they're on a run they're on a run
here
okay give me the Block in the wall I got
I know how to play now I swear I'm sorry
give me the ball give DJ the ball all
right
oops what did you learn oh they wanna
chat wants you to end the game with a
three-point shot okay you finish it off
if they give you the rock give me the
rock
no not him haha sizzle and they're like
playing keep-away with you oh that was a
good pass you can still end it on a
three
[Music]
[Applause]
I see some people talking about the
special like special editions
collector's editions what does this game
come with I guess you guys know and chat
the extra editions
oh you're a B+ let's go oh I shoulda
shot it two rebounds two assists DJ oh
yeah there's your three pointer
there's your buckets guys it's nice
everyone reload the three cannon nice
there we go DJ you played awesome a lot
of people are watching you today how
does it feel being out there it's a lot
of fun I mean you have so many great
guys out there the competition is fierce
and I'm just happy we got the win at the
showdown game alright DJ we all know
what happens but let me say for 2k TV I
will be on the cover of the game well
we're definitely rooting for you you
played awesome today and thank you for
coming on the show
thanks yes I'm with double bow here this
is very corny shirt look at her shirt I
know
oh great game DJ Ronny 2k yeah it is I
love that that just covered it up excuse
me I'm sorry I
I run scouting for the New York Knicks
oh yeah I'm glad you're back in the port
man where you belong
I watched you summon to hate you and
then I hear that you're gonna throw it
all away to do some music listen that
kind of looks like a chubby damn marina
no we don't have one representing most
of the contact between the teams and the
players were looking into is supposed to
go through nature so thanks for your
time so all you had to do is say yes I
have an agent lied
well I don't know like if you pick that
option do you actually have an agent
flat bread says we look like a Jason
Kidd it doesn't look like jck that's how
it works no cuz I don't know but he
offered you a tryout
yes he offered me trying let's get you
an agent I don't know any people oh I
know what it's doing his name's Andre
he's no my little twin little tasty you
don't tell my face to have it that but
the point is that he got me that casting
thing with the commercial commercial you
didn't get the commercial but he told me
when and where it was you never went to
the commercial the point I'm good I
don't want to meet Andre but they okay
Oh hold up this dude was handing out
business cards from the from the Jordan
event earlier wait wait let me tell you
sir hey I met you at the Jordan event I
wanted to come by the office to talk
come on hold a hollow I got something
awesome he said uh say yeah he's got an
office nearby he's sending the location
over always go in the office right now
[Music]
so what is this place I'm feeling the
same way what just happened my bill
because I won't have the Internet
no please me ah what can I do how are
you talking to me now yes yes come
you're really you're from the Jordan
thing right yeah yeah yeah you can play
a bit have a seat have a seat
Thank You Man I appreciate it and I
think so and so does the scouter the New
York Knicks he wants me to try out for
the team tomorrow morning Larry
yes I think so Larry he's gonna polo
shirt yeah yeah he's there scout so they
want you to go to the workout tomorrow
well okay so here's the thing I don't
have an official tryout but he asked me
if I had an agent I said no he said he
can't talk to me so that's where you
come in right your might be my middle
man that's where I come in right right
yes you want me to pick up the phone and
call Larry and fix the mystic you got
yourself into by telling him you didn't
have a name well that's the idea I mean
if you can do that I'm gonna get a
whuppin just go find somebody else my
friend I would like to offer you my
services as your agent wait are you
serious man just like that you yeah we
do you think we can do this oh you're an
incredible baller this is your moment
don't you understand tomorrow tomorrow
will be the first biggest day of your
entire career your foots in the door and
in this business if you sign one
contract you're set for years do you
sign too you're set for a lifetime I
could be getting a little yeah he's self
this is great this is your moment hey
you need to be home resting
it's an early thing tomorrow right yeah
yeah drink some water stay hydrated so
you'll talk to him I will and you sir
are gonna learn
how to eat what you kill what does it
mean DJ in this business you don't eat
unless you take food out of somebody
else's mouth tomorrow you need to go in
the vent work yeah so hungry so
desperately you think you're gonna
starve to death unless you grab a big
fat juicy roster spot out of the jaws of
every other player there who wants it
just as badly as you do yeah eat what
you can't eat what you kill eat what you
kill
oh my god oh that's interesting it just
cuts to load from that the next day feel
like there should have been a fade there
next day
all right this is your this is your
house
oh baby that mellow even I hope it nice
thanks for coming
hey I said thanks for coming hey hey I'm
DJ okay DJ I'm the assistant coach ready
yes same hairstyle he's bald a little
bit I see what this is you know a while
back I was in your exact same position
yeah went undrafted sweat it out for the
summer and then I got invited to workout
didn't know what to expect man I was so
nervous I was more nervous than I've
ever been
you nervous I'm just happy to be here oh
good for you I was nervous knees were
shaking
knocking all together I was like the
shook ones you know sequel to the sequel
part three you know what don't even
worry about a young brother that's
before your time but I got a scrimmage I
want to get you into okay yo bring it in
scrimmage
let's see you were playing with where's
porzingis all right guys Cory he's gonna
be running with you on the next round
give him a little taste of how we get
down in the NBA
yeah what's going on man DJ never mind
good it's good is it I just lost Ashley
finds the back of his name
I see Mel over here I don't see one else
is cool
I can't do anything right now all right
Oh Ron control on controller look at
that core so beautiful oh it's open
no the other guy there he is oh I like
how they didn't give me a Jersey I'm
just straight up in my messy clothes I
wonder if they can you does anyone know
if you play summer league we're gonna be
make the team wonder to get the place
summer they'll be sick if you cave you
did to cable you just change I changed
Oh
nice good pass
oh yes oh yeah I didn't set my feet
there
Oh coast to coast
got a man open the corner Oh had to hold
the ball to one I freed it up sir
perfect sessions on the side I lost more
than a game yeah I just heard it now
late that was weird
Oakland is actually underrated I was
hoping the words you tried to get
O'Quinn somehow
oh there's Baker your boy Baker oh I
didn't mean oh but it worked out okay
there you go
good ball movement no you got a lot of
positive there all those you I thought I
could maybe pick his pocket if she's got
by as a mistake
ya heard the I heard the basket again
maybe it's on the other Court sheds at a
corner three are you homer away I'm away
nice nice
oh yes look good Nick it did actually
that was probably the cleanest look but
you got positive points there so we've
got to get you some more system high and
they're not hitting their jump shots
right
it happen
good ball movement you're almost said to
be lose oh I'm gonna have to disagree
with NFL 2k I really like Madden Madden
this year is one of my faves
hold l1 and call for a screen thanks for
the tip I'll try that right now pay
attention to stamina says Ravi Luke
oh okay all right get it out I try to
force it okay
that was open yes step down bounce we're
just down ten points that's all right
103 remaining I don't know what that
clock means roll off that for me I guess
I gotta tell him
Oh give me that this nice there you go
me - lets go appreciate it
thanks for the tips
all right there we go I don't know what
that sound is
oh it might be the other chords it
sounds like it's like right there 100k
drum pal that's good oh my gosh shoot
free throws great Oh No
how does how do we is just like where it
goes why in the line I don't know so to
early yeah so I guess right at the top
of the oh that's way too early what
that's my fault I didn't hold on to it
too eager
missed all free throw C+ I'm gonna be a
star not gonna waste my shot I
definitely wasted my job oh and Hardaway
jr. DJ how do you feel about another run
oh I feel okay about another sorry oh
sure yes sir absolutely positive yep
I'll put you in this game you tell me
your time and be upset because you just
told me you weren't tired I understood I
mean I could find another guy it's
nothing I'm your guy coach good I want
to see you again start us over here I
played horribly against the second oh
boy all right later gamer 32 thanks for
stopping by so I'm gonna put you in this
next scrimmage over here uncle guys
listen
DJ's trying out good against the tubes
but the coaching staff wants to see what
he's really made up so don't get all
precious on me I need you to give him
the business okay please I think so yeah
Portuguese looks okay
he doesn't like grape adduce okay the
hair spot on
oh we had him so you're you're playing
with the B squad
I'm playing with the oh this is their
new when they pick up the number one
pick we're doing guys dude how am I
supposed to box out at her nangou Gomez
B style so I say the same thing
porzingis looks really small come on
baby D up on them oh wow Oh a block that
good foul
sure that's considered a good foul
really yes follow the Corden's don't lie
what I didn't read it but what did it
say just now when I missed that shot
Phil link correctly that's good
oh is that you yes lightly late well
your other chefs are slightly early so I
figured right at that threshold now it
takes a while to get used to like the
shooting oh that was sick
get tick oh nice it takes a little while
to get used to your timing of shots and
stuff sessions is open if you want to
hit em for three
step back no choice and no choice
we're nine o'clock I wanted to pass to
the guy that cut down low
yeah I agree chat porzingis looks a
little small it's weird like your what
do we make our characters six six two
six three six three and he like kind of
stacks up with porzingis porzingis is
definitely torn now let me see how
Italians don't even know in chat
he's exactly got one shot no you missed
the first one are you yeah this kid's
gonna start yeah
Oh Chris tops from nello he's seven
three as people said yeah he doesn't
look seven three in here at all
porzingis right yes short for thanks
Jeff
to pass chat wants you to pass in the
build your score up unless you can dunk
on Oh
all right now go ahead good ball
movement so you're fine
Wow he wasn't even out about it
2:59 just down a little bit
oh nice swoosh oh trying to build up the
score for the chat swing swing swing
Oh early whistle all right you're only
like one or two good passes away from
Abbi I think maybe a b-plus I am not
sure if this demo is gonna come out on
the switch I know it's only available
we're playing on PlayStation right now I
know it's available on Xbox one as well
oh there we go nice this guy use that
pick and roll man the full game will be
on the switch we know we checked that
earlier two dimes sucks you're on the
next dude no it doesn't that's great
you play in the greatest city in the
world but was awesome I would have
picked the dubs of course he would have
I've been a Warriors fan since I was a
kid that perspective and every right to
celebrate now that we've anyone anyone
that has become a Warriors fan in the
last two three seasons I do not respect
I'm sorry I've known I've known that all
the struggles of way back in the day
Chris Gatling djr Oh take it - yeah I
know flatbread one-on-one the Knicks are
gonna be bad this year but okay I'm not
a fair-weather fan I stick with my team
when they're good when they're bad when
they're in transition on their building
because that's what fans did it's what
we're supposed to do I will never be a
bandwagon fan ever
I do expect them to trade melons
I don't know when but they will I said I
was gonna take mellow my [ __ ] shot it on
him
just to see if I could make it on them
I just box me out well I got a garden
mello 101 in the post he's only like
three or more Hardaway how much money
they pay Hardaway they paid him like a
ridiculous amount of money to come back
didn't they like way too much money no
not you oh he's got to make that shot
yeah it's right 71 million for four
years Hardaway jr. insane that's way too
much money
pick it up
nice sessions for three he's sure and
everything you're almost to a B+ right
here oh no take that bow that was good
though you two three right I have been a
Knicks fan since Ewing Sprewell Houston
haste really well I was on the Warriors
first before we keep chokes I was saving
there's definitely a spot on this team
for player with your skill set oh hey
Shane Amanda change well I'm just a
sister coach
I don't do the silence but I do make
recommendations and I would recommend to
the front office and the coach this is a
moving very skill set your size and we
can play ball the way you do and they
should potentially sign that guy so tell
your agent that we'll be in touch
potential I don't think this is how this
works
of course no it wouldn't have been that
easy
yeah no I don't think this is how that's
all right though I actually don't feel
like I played that well I feel like I'm
a d-league player right now well you did
over now we'll see if it is it is it
seems like a good time anyways if it is
where it stops we probably should have
did some 2k you yeah we thought we had
graduated college but we had not yet
just mere high school varsity don't do
it don't go in that door guess what you
met Kobe
not even close you made the NBA Yes No
maybe maybe maybe hold on are you an
official how the Aniston's get tickets
NBA player I mean maybe I could be oh my
are you gonna play against Kobe no no no
charge with Tiger get the endorsements
no sorry you know hosting thing hi I
can't be saying no what what Joe DEA
agent texted me Holy See he said he's
coming over right now he says you're not
gonna believe this no this is happening
yo it's happening it's happening DJ
that's it
I think I think so there's a new cover
the game there he is there he is the man
himself Kyrie Irving what do you think
about that that Kyrie trade I went to
camera on us for a second ah I think it
was not good for the Celtics really
really why do you say that I think that
everything that they gave away is like
way more valuable than having them cuz
realistically how many more seasons he
have that's like an elite point guard
how old is he how check out oh yeah we
looked this up he's got a good
he's got a good I think he needs five
years at least 25 or 24 oh he could
still okay so we finished yeah let me go
back to this real quick we did finish
the story and we're gonna go to K you
really hurry is only 25 is what it is
okay I'm just double-checking that
Jersey boy he's 25 so I think he could
easily play into his 30s now I don't
like as long as he doesn't get hurt but
NY crellick the 2ky relic will help you
learn how to master the moves and
mechanics if I guess did you start
basing out there so you can play all the
next NBA superstone yeah Wincy on Twitch
I mean he's saying Nick was saying how
many years left do I think cross the
Jerry has he plays for 10 years more but
do you think that all the draft picks
that they gave up is that worth but
they've been saving up for this day like
they've been trying to I don't know they
still have like another number one right
like trading trading Isaiah is fine but
giving up Crowder along with it seems
crazy to me they had to you think the
Cavs were gonna accept less the fact
that they have to give another second
just because Isaiah Thomas isn't playing
someone told me Isaiah Thomas is not
playing to an all-star pass tap that
truth so we said what is the left stick
to select the receiver
someone told me Isaiah Tom
this is not going to be playing until
after all-star break ah why because of
his hit I don't I didn't look that up I
didn't think that that was I didn't
think the trade would go through if that
was the case I think that's why this is
so there was like so much going on
match match keel juice that they also
traded Bradley to the fish and shake my
head yeah it's actually really
interesting because like they basically
in a way blew up their team right they
did they basically blew up their team
rent hold sprint they you know let's
let's think about who's left you got
Horford you got Jay Lynn Brown you got
obviously starting new starting point
guard Kyrie you have a new shooting
guard small forward depending on where
he plays in Gordon Hayward
so it's oh he can make that so yeah I
don't know interesting but the Cavs did
also because yeah yeah Boston knew that
they were gonna be able to keep Thomas
anyways probably because they you know
he probably wants a lot of money yeah so
that also makes sense shoot the ball I
think Boston's team might be pretty good
we'll see I mean it's definitely the
East is gonna be more interesting now
yeah flatbread 101 I missed the Paul
Pierce Ray Allen cagey Celtics yeah that
was pretty cool different like the not
the original big three because they'd
some has said it originates way farther
than that but I enjoyed watching them as
well it was a pretty good Ray Allen has
always been a player that was fun
watching there were three dedicated
buttons for passing pass bounce pass
over the pass I mean I don't know I mean
how much more time we have we're pretty
much pretty good to go
we do get to see the Warriors here
though draymond would never make that he
wouldn't not even if he was like making
multiple threes
he's like top of the key is his best boy
or not top of the key but top like you
know what I mean in the middle
these starting squats a good separate
Kevin lovers box outside that's why we
needed Zaza we need to keep was odd
because the pro stick he stopped Kristin
cold shoot then release yeah anyone
that's it I don't know who said Kyrie
plays like Nash but that is definitely
not the case you can switch the camera
too if you hit the d-pad slightly
earlier if you hit the d-pad I think
right or left I think it switches a
camera what do you want to do focus on
staying home want players on defense
press player swamp to commander Thomas
Ashley clear SWA the ball play on that
2k camera I thought it was on the d-pad
to change the 2k camera
it wasn't the this is a focus on yeah
well anyway bless you stick clogged
removes great sticker tapping l to did
you give it time
that's
oh oh yeah I don't know why pass it back
out know like how there's no shot clock
here you want to place your warriors
I'll play for like a hot second but I
try to change you can't change the
camera up either someone says press
option to throw us key gonna just a
camera to target a receiver farther away
yeah skip pass yeah so again this is the
NBA 2k 18 free loot demo we could only
play through it once so we played
through the pre loot so this is just 2 K
you yeah it's much better getting some
practice in warriors Cavs but yeah I
mean I agree the most people in the chat
with the trade but I just think that
Boston lost a lot of future pics that
could have been important yeah you can't
just keep stockpiling decay no you can't
but I think that they were they'd spent
a fair amount of time building something
and then when the opportunity came to
pick up Kyrie they like took all these
plans that they had in place for a while
and they just kind of went all-in on
Kyrie which could work out I think it
could work out but I also think that it
could it could come back to bite him in
a couple seasons
if Kyrie gets injured if the blocks the
pieces that they try to put around him
don't work out use the shock meter isn't
8 while shooting uh two times wants to
know on twitch one is the official
release date I think it's September 19th
isolation like that we're a spot on
YouTube says GameSpot use curry and
shoot from the shoot from three the
percent what does it say let's see you
try to shoot from way out yeah he's
notorious for making shots from there
let's see what it is dude I held on Oh
it shot release when the meter is full
this gives you the highest percentage
shot all right we'll try that again
Oh from deep three all right a yeah
we'll get III III screwed that up if I
even dude what is Steph looks like he's
not that much bigger than I T right I
know I asked the chat earlier but for
any everybody that's still in there now
for those of you played the 2k teen demo
versus the EA live what do you guys
prefer which one are you planning on
purchasing when they both come out I
don't know I think the Celtics also
knowing now like if LeBron
hypothetically we use Cleveland next
year which I think he will I think he
will - I think like he's a Laker bow he
just like dominating to use for like a
while but then again like then does that
hurt oh man
I feel bad for like Isaiah to deuce I
wonder if this is gonna come blow I mean
obviously he can't control what goes on
liquor was cheap because he wasn't a
free agent but if you if he leaves
Cleveland then what happens is it fall
apart is Boston run the East for the
next like three years I don't like the
parity though nice typical Warriors
basketball Oh what come on
I should have so much Lee Lewis Steph on
a three that's ridiculous to perform a
steal like that says you can have a
perfect release from half-court with
Steph with Steph if you can't yeah I
mean obviously gonna time it perfectly
chalo I will try again here we go Oh
house looks pretty good that's pretty
close nothing's for you guys there
alright we'll try one more three that's
worth that's gonna be it the half court
I tried from a half court there I think
we've pretty much exhausted everything
that 2k has in this demo Isiah looks
good in the Cavs Jersey it's gonna be
interesting now that this is weird
yeah why are we Ruffin how many of you
in the chat have already pre-ordered 2k
18 if you have obviously the demo ends
with the opportunity for you to
pre-order the digital download to sprint
holy print and move the left stick in
any direction already told me that it's
too late all right
oh great care does this stop and shimmy
I just moved under sentence needs help
Isiah that's alright
Isiah might be able to make that but can
he make one of these was too late or too
early also for any of you guys that you
know read about all the trade talk and
stuff and Isaiah left and those in
Boston who felt like they were
devastated in there they were hurt you
should check out if you don't have the
time
sit down pull up the players Tribune and
read Isaiah's kind of letter to Boston
and like how he perceived what went on
it's awesome it'll like make it rethink
things like I was a big KD hater I kind
of still am because I felt like oh oh
wow I kind of felt like what he was
doing was just you know doing whatever
it takes to get the to get rings and
whatnot but when you look at it he's
just being a smart businessman like
can't knock somebody for making a good
decision that's gonna like benefit him
financially in the future and it's a oh
I thought that was going perfect same
same with Isaiah like it wasn't up to
him to make this like it wasn't up to
him to to be traded or not and it was a
business decision for Boston but you
have time go read that go read that uh
that players Tribune article it's so
good this is a beginner so if you hit
change tutorial to advance it'll do like
the more advanced stuff but I was just
using to shooter we only got one of
those perfect ones
all right all right this is legit last
three I'm gonna try one more right here
I'm plagued oh it's too far it sounds
like no get another chances press
overhead pass use the left stick to
select the receiver dark cloud 1983 this
is not the switch we're currently
playing on PlayStation 4 it's actually a
pro oh you made it awful what it said
slightly early and everything to you
his percent get that out of here trying
to make a lay up on me get out of here I
was this gonna be a foul so I blocked it
100% okay
oh I knew I was going to LeBron oh he's
too big
LeBron King James hurry up LeBron LeBron
don't make Fritos here we go where do
you think LeBron goes but he inevitably
leaves Cleveland in the LA I'm I'm
saying
Lakers it's like a I'd say a 70% chance
oh that's pretty close oh that's it all
right thanks everyone for watching that
was MBA 2k 18 Prelude demo you can get
that now for free xbox one ps4 I believe
full releases September 19th
so coming soon and yeah I hope you guys
enjoyed it I hope you guys may or may
not be picking up NBA 2k thanks Nick for
hanging out playing its UK he's free she
ate it it's fun I'm looking forward to
seeing how the story goes yeah cool see
you guys later
we'll be live tomorrow again 11 a.m.
Destiny's children live stream here
that's the US and UK kind of
co-production we stream destiny to on
Tuesdays and then there's it long play
video with the UK folks two more Lucy
and Dave on Friday so you guys should
check that out Lobby on Wednesday of
course but until then we'll see you guys
later peace out peace